welcome to the David packman show I am
Farren cousins from Ring of Fire sitting
in for David packman today and man do we
have a great show coming up for you
we've gotten more potential charges that
could be filed against Donald Trump
we've got Jim Jordan getting smacked
down by Manhattan district attorney
Alvin Bragg we've got Maga freaks coming
out in droves to attack former Trump
lawyer Jenna Ellis all that and much
much more is coming up so let's jump
right into it as I mentioned
there could be a new Avenue for Jack
Smith the special prosecutor with the
doj to charge Trump with even more
crimes than previously thought thanks to
a ruling last week a three-judge panel
actually overturned a lower court judge
Carl Nichols Who was appointed by Trump
uh Nichols had ruled that prosecutors
trying the capital rioters could not
charge those individuals with
obstructing an official Congressional
proceeding
the official proceeding of course being
the certification of the Electoral
College votes and for some reason judge
Nichols said nope even though they very
obviously obstructed and postponed that
hearing through their actions
you can't charge them with that
so then late last week a three-judge
panel voted two to one that yeah
yeah you can charge these individuals
with obstructing an official
Congressional proceeding
now what's important about that
according to former assistant Manhattan
district attorney Andrew Weissman is
that now that this three-judge panel
has given permission for prosecutors to
use that obstruction charge Weissman
says that Jack Smith could now with that
permission
file those same charges potentially
against Donald Trump let me read you
what Weissman had to say during an
appearance on msnbc's Morning Joe
this is really a gift for Jack Smith
because as good as it is for the
Washington D.C prosecutors who have
hundreds of pending cases who want to
know that this is a charge they can
continue charging Jack Smith is going to
be thinking about this obstruction
charge with respect to the former
president
there's nothing better for Jack Smith
than to know that this has already been
approved by the DC circuit meaning he
can charge it and unless the Supreme
Court disagrees with the D.C circuit he
knows that this is a rock solid legally
a legal Rock Solid charge that he has to
prove it factually but getting the sort
of pre-clearance is unusual to have and
he has to be happy that the Court ruled
that this is a charge that will stick
for any potential charge he is thinking
with respect to the former president
a lot to take in right let me distill
that down to its most basic components
obviously the first thing you have is
the United States Supreme Court it's
likely this will obviously be challenged
and head to the U.S Supreme Court at
which point the justices
most likely given the magnitude of this
uh you know charge I don't think they'll
take it up
I think they'll look at that three-judge
panel ruling two to one vote and
basically come to the decision we don't
want to wade into this
if they come to that decision they will
say nope we are not taking the case the
DC circuits decision stand that clears
the way for Jack Smith of course to hit
Trump with these obstruction charges if
they choose to take it up God only knows
how that's going to end up right we have
seen this court absolutely railroad
legal precedent
we don't know
so there's a big question mark over that
so 50 50 chance they take it up then if
they take it up 50 50 chance there that
they rule that yes you can charge these
individuals so let's assume for a moment
the Jack Smith gets the clearance the
Supreme Court either doesn't take it up
or rules in favor of the DC circuit and
Smith can charge Donald Trump with
obstruction of an official proceeding
that's a relatively minor charge
compared to obviously everything else
that Jack Smith is investigating so if
Smith moves forward and decides to
charge Donald Trump with obstruction
it's going to be a very minor charge on
top of everything else that he could
potentially be charging him with so it's
basically a way to just kind of pad
everything a little bit more
but I don't think that's where Jack
Smith is really wanting to put all of
his chips
because to me what I'm reading into this
is that if you can charge any of these
people involved in the events of January
6th with obstructing an official
government proceeding
that is something that Jack Smith can
then use as a bargaining chip
against any of the individuals who may
not want to cooperate fully with the
investigation maybe we want to plead the
fifth maybe we we don't want to come
talk to you maybe we want to challenge
these subpoenas of course we've seen all
this happen so far to no avail on the
part of most of the people that have
been subpoenaed
but this would give Jack Smith a really
great bargaining chip because it's a
fairly simple and easy charge to prove
and it's also something that most
prosecutors would not want to waste
their time pursuing
but if he can take that and dangle that
potential charge in front of any witness
that may not want to fully cooperate and
say listen
you don't have to tell me everything you
can plead the fifth if you want but I
just want you to know that here in my
back pocket
I have obstructing an official
government proceeding and I can charge
you with this it's very obvious that
your involvement on that particular day
led to the postponement of that
Electoral College vote and that is
illegal
so
I don't want to hit you with these
charges
but I'm more than willing to do it if
you do not cooperate
now some people may hear that and think
wow that kind of seems a little a little
underheaded but trust me it's not things
like this happen all the time in
criminal prosecutions and investigations
across the country every day
when you can find those little smaller
charges you know the obstructing
government proceeding obstruction of
justice by the way is usually the
bargaining chip that prosecutors will
use
to get people to testify and come
forward with information basically
offering an immunity deal right like I'm
not going to charge you with this as
long as you give me all of this
it is very common and to me that kind of
seems like the most likely Avenue that
Jack Smith would pursue if he gets the
clearance to bring those charges
that's not to say that he's not going to
go ahead and Tack that on to Donald
Trump because I do believe that's
something you could do just to you know
stretch out whatever else you got why
not hit him with everything and that is
probably what would happen if he's able
to do this again it's going to depend on
the Supreme Court that's one of those
wait and see moments that I know none of
us like
but that's where we stand right now
could be a new charge against Donald
Trump could be a bargaining chip either
way the wins at his back right Jack
Smith holds all the cards right now so
let's see what he does with it